what is that joke that you told recently
at the office i said i wish i was high
on pot news
these nuts were low against your chin
that's not it
that's not it that's not
all
all right how's everybody how's
everybody doing
all right and you guys can all hear me
okay all right i know this guy can right
here boy this guy's ears are so big he's
laughing at jokes from the yuck yuck
club all the way in the other side of
town
all right
and you sir you're doing okay right and
you're getting enough to eat
is that even possible
thank you sir
folks i'm sorry i'm gonna get everybody
tonight i'm gonna nobody is safe i'm
getting everybody except for you sir i'm
going to leave you alone just like your
date did tonight hello
all right
okay who's next
who is next
hey ma'am
i get it you have breasts okay
geez i mean look at this chick over here
her cleavage is giving the grand canyon
an inferiority complex
skipped me
who's who's talking right now
me
yeah hey man look at that look at that
pink shirt you got on there wow where'd
you get that
queer
t-shirts.com
it's in support of breast cancer
awareness
i am gay though
okay go for it
i can take it
hmm oh yeah yeah no hey yeah don't you
worry about that man
gloves are coming off
okay
right there right there what's with the
three drinks man alcoholic much
this is my pain
medication
of course it is it's your pain
medication
because uh
he is in pain
right now make fun of the birds
[Music]
make fun of the what did you say
because here's the problem sir is it's
really dark in here and sorry are you
burned because i can't make it out
thanks so much ma'am for illuminating
him thank you that's uh i appreciate
that
oh
those burns make fun of the robot voice
sir i don't know come on i can take it
oh okay well no you know what i feel
like a wheelchair look sir there is
nothing funny about you being in a
wheelchair and we can all but there is
something funny about me being fat
all right no all right fine fine i've
got it i've got it i'm doing it i'm
doing it i just didn't want to go after
this guy because i didn't want him to
kill me in my dreams
like like freddy krueger
no
no did you have freddy krueger's face is
burned off
that's not
[Applause]
you
asked
he said he could take it that's what he
said i thought i could but i can't how's
this on me how do we even know if he's
crying right now
well i don't know that sound it just
sounds like an electronic sound
[Applause]
the right triangle's longest side is
called the hypotenuse
and it's this side here let's see the
longest one i wish i were high on hot
news
i wish i was high on pot news
[Applause]
okay okay
oh mr morrison's very funny it's very
funny but let's get back to the lesson
if you can see the longest one where it
goes from this point that was my joke
i know man that was hilarious of a
triangle i've labeled them here a b and
c no but i mean i said that i labeled
anything i said it say that they're i
said it
i said that please please mr jackson
keep your comments to yourself
thank you
now the hypotenuse
and you really got me on that one oh so
great oh oh principal martel principal
martel come here come here come here uh
tell principal martel what you said troy
oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and i said i wish i was high on pot news
[Applause]
i'm sorry
he likes it
principal martel is cool
that's a very funny prisoner martel
principal martel i said that mr jackson
that is enough what i said at first
oh uh mr iglesias mr iglesias yes come
in come in
yeah
what's up people's coffee
comedian giveaway iglesias is touring
the local schools today for a charity
he's working on tell him what you said
tell me what you said
oh
i wish i was high on pot noose
oh my god that is clever that is good
very funny
great buddy
right no thanks mr iglesias mr iglesias
uh i'm your biggest fan that was my joke
uh you know it's not really cool buddy
to take credit for other people's jokes
hey listen funny stuff i'm doing this
big tour right now you want to see about
maybe we could talk about your opening i
need an opener
oh
um sure
what do you think is that okay of course
what
sorry about that it's talent nice to
meet you thanks so much richard pryor
get over here man come on
he deserved it
all right so across from the longest
side is a 90 degree angle
good thing i've got a 90 degree dangle
yo stop it you will never be troy
why are you trying to be like troy
dick
a two nerdy girl
so
the hypotenute
thank you
mike cody yeah hey how are you man good
to see hey i'm glad i ran into you what
is that joke that you told recently at
the office everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time and i
haven't heard it yet oh gosh okay um all
right it goes like this
so there's this woman
okay
good audience i'm sorry i love it
already i love it already
awesome okay well this should go well
um
so there's this uh woman
and she goes to her doctor
[Laughter]
no i haven't even gotten to the setup
yet
so she goes to her doctor and she um
she says to her doctor uh kiss me
no that's not it
that's not it that's not not the
punchline
you gotta stop man you're killing me
over here yeah
i don't know if you think the joke is
over but it's not it's actually just
starting
[Laughter]
okay so i'm gonna i'm just gonna speed
it up so she says to her doctor kiss me
and he says i can't it would be
unprofessional
no
no not even close
she says
she says that would be unprofessional
and then she says she keeps asking him
and he says no no no that was three
times like that
finally at the end she says
kiss me and he says
i shouldn't even be having sex with you
right now
then what happens
i i don't i don't know then
i guess she
should probably sued him for malpractice
[Laughter]
so you know that wasn't that wasn't the
punch line
that wasn't the punchline no the punch
there's more
there's not more
you know there's actually less
what is it turning around
no there's
a
the joke was it can't be the punchline
was the only part that you didn't laugh
at
what the [ __ ]
you got me you're doing a joke the whole
time
you were doing a weird character the
whole time
yes yes i love the malpractice stuff the
male
punchline is hilarious so you aren't
doing a character
what character what character this is
some crazy [ __ ]
[Music]
vince
i uh i have that quarterly analysis that
you asked for
i had a quarter of these nuts on your
chin
right
it's just that i wanted to review some
of these numbers with you it seems like
our earnings are low against our
original projections
these nuts were low against your chin
[Music]
you know vince
if you ever need to talk to me about
something i'm more than happy to listen
these nuts will be more than happy to
rest against your chin
hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kind of
funny at first these nuts were kind of
funny against your chin
vince i'm worried about you
[Music]
i was worried about these nuts on your
chin
stand seriously
[Music]
these nuts were seriously on your chin
mr graham i just got a call from st
mary's hospital and your parents were in
a serious car accident
i'm so sorry
but your mother is dead
and your father is on life support
[Music]
these nuts are supporting life on your
chin
sorry amber
vince you gotta stop it your mother just
passed away he's nuts passed away on
your [ __ ] no they didn't
they didn't vince
listen you gotta leave here right now
and go be with your dad this could be
the last time that you get to see him
it's gonna be the last time i get to see
my nuts on youtube god damn it vincent
your father might be dying
these nuts might be dying on your chin
[Music]
god damn it fence snap the [ __ ] out of
it
your mother is dead
all right
all right
you okay okay you're all right you're
back
i don't know what came over me that's
all right it was so good
it was just
it worked in every situation
i know i know and it's always it's just
so funny well it wasn't it wasn't that
funny it was funny
it really wasn't that funny vince
really funny
i would not go so far as to say it was
really funny vince was funny
but it wasn't though
it was
it wasn't
afraid to disagree it's funny okay
that's fine
one more time i just got one record and
saying it wasn't really that funny
that was funny
wasn't that funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dad
stay with me
dad
i love you
and i love
these nuts on your chin
ah
coolio man
oh yeah certainly
oh hey i gotta go
yeah terry out
sarah how you doing man hey pretty good
gabe oh
got something on your shirt
not today terry
it's like gabe's come out to play
[Music]
you do have something on your shirt no i
don't yeah you kind of do i'm pretty
sure i don't got a clean shirt at my
desk if you want me to get it for you i
don't see why that would be necessary
well because the stretch you have on
right now it's not clean except for that
it is me i have a clean shirt you you
have some schmutz on your jammies no
there is no schmutz at my jammie jam
you know what
why don't i just get it for you yeah why
don't you do that
[Music]
and there we go did you get it
i almost got you
close almost i mean i'm thinking damn
you good
but you know what the funny thing is
what's that
now i guess from when i dabbed your
shirt with the paper towel and i'm not
playing the game right now but i
actually i must have got some paper
towel fuzz on your shirt so
[Music]
hey
how long has karen wearing her hair up
like that
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i don't should have to go through that
and i i'm sorry it happened
hey terry what's going on
uh having a good morning
i'm having a
terrific morning
great
hope there's nothing on my shirt because
i can't look down
[Music]
oh no dude we're not doing that right
now okay
there's nothing on your shirt no one
cares about your shirt
everything's not about you
i'm trying to have a conversation with
karen right now
so
[Music]
you okay terry just pisses me off
um
[Music]
oh yeah yeah i do have schmutz there's
all over me now
you can't deny that terry's not going to
know what hit him
i will win i win
[Music]
what what happened
terry died
[Music]
be right back
hey terry
[Music]
it's gabe
i um
just wanted to let you know that um
that you didn't get me terry
you didn't get me
because on the day that you died there
was schmutz on my shirt so guess who
wins the game terry
i do i win
you lose
[Music]
he flipped me
oh
[Music]